luz verde al acuerdo de alberto
fernández con el fondo monetario
internacional el senado argentino aprobó
el pacto que ya había recibido el visto
bueno de la cámara de diputados ahora
debe ser revisado una vez más por el fm
para entrar en vigor en el debate hubo
cruce de opiniones entre los que lo
apoyaban y los detractores
apeló a la consideración de las señoras
senadores y señores senadores para que
acompañen la aprobación del proyecto de
ley en tratamiento
señora presidenta la cuestión central
que debemos decidir en esta tarde es de
fonsi o de fondo con todo lo que ello
implicaría entrar en mora y no pagar
el acuerdo establece un nuevo programa
de financiamiento de 30 meses con el fm
por 45.000 millones de dólares deuda
adquirida por el ex presidente mauricio
macri mientras se debatía frente del
congreso se reunieron cientos de
personas que están en desacuerdo y
nosotros creemos que las estafas no se
pagan como antes de recibir en dentro
con todos nuestros gobernantes como
pagar la deuda me parece que antes
tendrían que a investigarla y ver dónde
se fugó toda esa plata porque al fin y
al cabo caes sobre el cuerpo de los
trabajadores y las trabajadoras
fernández llegó a un principio de
acuerdo con el fm y en febrero y su
aprobación en el congreso argentino
otorga un alivio a los pagos previstos
entre este año y 2024